[Music]
straight ahead on loan crime daily
complete coverage of day 18 in the
johnny depp amber herb defamation trial
what tape did you provide to the mail
online the daily mail i provided them
two tapes depp's attorney adam waldman
is deposed and was johnny depp's career
on the downward before his divorce from
amber hearn his
star had dimmed due to
it getting harder to get him jobs plus i
remember clearly talking that we had no
other option that night but then to use
a red blood like a really red lipstick
to
you know make sure we could cover up
the injuries on the lip heard's makeup
artist testifies about seeing injuries
on the actress before a public
appearance and later the clock is
ticking as a strict deadline approaches
i promise the story would be done by
memorial day weekend and we will be done
by memorial day weekend law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer johnny
depp's attorney takes the stand as amber
heard accuses him of orchestrating a
smear campaign against her in the media
and social media
law and crimes anjan levy is here with
what adam waldman said and wouldn't say
antoinette
well brian adam waldman's testimony
played by a video deposition and there
were so many questions that he couldn't
answer because johnny depp's attorney in
the defamation lawsuit ben chu
advised him not to answer the questions
because doing so could violate
attorney-client privilege now adam
waldman's testimony was presented by
amber heard to support her counter claim
of defamation against johnny depp heard
claims that adam waldman launched a
smear campaign against her when he
responded to her abuse claims in news
stories and in tweets one of those news
stories was a daily mail mail story that
was referenced today in testimony
said the various discrepancies prove
that nothing heard and her friend said
about the events of may 21 2016 could be
considered credible do you see that
should you say
then i'm going to direct your attention
mr waldman to the next statement
quote quite simply this was an ambush a
hoax
they set mr depp up by calling the cops
but the first attempt didn't do the
trick
the officers came to the penthouses
thoroughly searched and interviewed and
left after seeing no damage to face or
property
so amber and her friends spilled a
little wine and roughed the place up got
their story straight under the direction
of a lawyer and a publicist and then
place the second call to 9-1-1 do you
see that statement
i do
did you make those statements
said nothing could be considered
credible that's not quoting me the part
with the quote marks i believe i said
that yes did you make this these
statements on mr depp's behalf
instruct the witness not to
answer on the grounds of attorney
calling privilege
i accept the instruction
and waldman testified that he also
provided two recordings audio recordings
of those arguments between amber heard
and johnny depp to the daily mail he
also said that twitter suspended him for
life think about that the only other
person i can think of who is suspended
for from twitter for life is president
donald trump and waldman said that he
wrote to twitter to try to figure out
why his account had been permanently
suspended he told was told there was an
appeal and then that appeal apparently
was lost so he never really got a clear
answer the suggestion though is that
twitter suspended him for life due to
those tweets about amber heard
hey maybe elon musk can get him back in
there if you buy his twitter but angenet
that's what i was thinking
but mr free speech right yeah so the
hashtags and dislike of amber heard seem
to generate from everywhere on social
media so based on what you've heard did
it seem like waldman is this kind of
leader of this smear campaign
you know it's so funny that you asked me
that because there has been all this
talk on twitter people kind of joke
about adam waldman running a bot farm
having all these russian bots out there
to support johnny depp but apparently
through some testimony today on
cross-examination of a social media
expert for amber heard they elicited
some testimony that the hashtag justice
for johnny depp had actually been around
since 2013. so i thought that was really
interesting so i'm not sure they've been
able to draw
you know a correlation or you know make
a nexus or whatever that adam waldman
somehow was responsible for any hate
directed at amber heard johnny depp of
course has fans around the world he's
been around a long time
so he has a lot of supporters yeah now
and
heard's attorneys must have known that
waldman wouldn't be able to answer
certain questions so why ask them and do
you think that makes it look like walden
is hiding something for depp
i don't think so i mean you're a lawyer
brian and you know if you don't if you
don't ask you know you kind of have to
throw it out there and see what you can
get you don't know if he'll end up
answering a question that we could give
you something that you could work with
so i'm surprised you know i've had
experiences before where attorneys won't
even tell me whether they're
representing somebody because they're
that private about it and they think
it'll violate some type of privilege so
there are some attorneys who are really
really guarded about those types of
things yeah i mean i can't talk to
anyone about the conversations i have
with my clients that's client attorney
privilege those are the questions they
seem to be asking i think every attorney
knows you're not going to answer that
but really quick at the end of it all
what were the major takeaways from this
testimony
well i think the major takeaways from
waldman's testimony was that he was
defending his client against something
that he considered to be false he also
said there were nine people that said
that you know corroborated
any claim you know that they were on the
side of this didn't happen
and he listed nine different people who
said they did not see any injuries to
amber heard's face that week after may
21st of 2016. obviously may 27th of 2016
is when amber heard requested that
restraining order and showed up at the
courthouse with the mark on her face
well thank you very much angeline great
reporting as always
still ahead on law and crime daily our
coverage continues in the johnny depp
amber heard defamation trial up next
jurors hear from depp's former manager
why she says depp's reputation in
hollywood
[Music]
welcome back our comprehensive coverage
of the johnny depp amber her defamation
trial continues with the video
deposition of depp's former agent she
testified depp's star power had dimmed
based on a negative reputation for his
onset work
earlier you said that mr depp's
reputation that he became the greatest
actor in the world right
that's not what i said but i said he
became the biggest movie star in the
world movie star thank you forgive me so
as of the time that you were terminated
by mr deb in october 2016
did you still believe that mr depp
was the greatest movie star in the world
no
why not
because his
star had dimmed due to
it getting harder to get him jobs given
the reputation that he had acquired due
to his
lateness and
and other things
and what were the other things
just you know
people were talking and the question was
out there
about
his behavior
and that behavior included
i think i've described it several times
would that behavior include
alcohol and drug use
yes
joining us today is former swat and
detective lisa lockwood lisa
is a fired agent the best witness for
herd do you think her testimony may be
colored based on how her relationship
with depp ended
yes anytime you have a situation where
somebody is no longer in your life
either financially a former employee or
a friend or even a relationship an ex
you're going to have potential for bias
so having her come up there and you can
clearly see in the way that she answered
her questions that she was anti-johnny
the way she was fired um the way the way
that she was let go saying the last 10
years were terrible and all we can say
with that is even those last 10 years
that she said that
johnny was in crisis mode and his star
had dimmed he did still continue to get
work in those 10 years and she was still
dually employed by him
yeah that's interesting because
even if depp's fame was diminishing and
i'm not saying it is or isn't he was an
actor for 38 years i think even after
she was fired he did one more pirates of
the caribbean movie and i think some of
the harry potter movies as well so
i don't know how that really works in
terms of him diminishing but also
couldn't amber heard's allegations
against him be something that adds to
that diminishing factor and then prove
him right
right and that would be part of it
that's what you need to actually look at
what were the contracts and certainly
johnny can produce that what happened to
him after all of the allegations came
out with her not the time period of
which she was fired and i think it was
several months after the entire um uh
projection that was put out to the media
that she had been battered so all all it
comes down to is looking at the timeline
of when he was offered jobs yeah i think
the summation is going to be just that a
giant timeline of his jobs these
allegations it's gonna be interesting to
see how both sides break them down thank
you very much lisa coming up on law and
crime daily we take a closer look at the
controversy surrounding amber heard's
makeup routine ahead winning testimony
for amber hertz team when the star's
makeup artist testifies did her really
have facial injuries that needed to be
covered up
[Music]
welcome back continuing now with our
coverage of the johnny depp v amber
heard trial as heard's makeup artist
testified via video deposition she
explained what steps she took to cover
what she says looked like bruises on
herd's face before an appearance on the
james corden show in 2015. and on
cross-examination depp's attorneys asked
her about her interactions with depp
when i
came to the penthouse of december 16 to
do amber's makeup
she had injuries
um
she had
two light like i don't know how i don't
know i mean i'm not a medical expert i
don't know how i would describe them but
it could have looked like somebody had
headbutted her lightly so she had a
discoloration here under both eyes and
on the bridge of the bridge of the nose
uh and she had
what i would call a split lip or
something on the lip we covered
you know the the discoloration or the
bruises
with a little slightly heavier concealer
although amber always you know
has a red lip is one of the signature
look i remember clearly talking that we
had no other option that night but then
to use a red blood like a really red
lipstick to
you know make sure we could cover up
the injuries on the limb what was your
impression of mr deb when you first met
him
lovely
you thought he was lovely
did you ever see mr deb
act in a violent manner
no did you ever see mr dab slap misheard
no
punch her
no it's fair to say missing lethia is
that
you never saw mr depp be physically
abusive towards misheard
correct
joining us is also his co-host terry
austin terry heard's makeup artist would
be in for lack of a better term an
expert asked to amber heard's face she
seems to be able to point out injuries
on her face and show when and where she
had to cover those those bruisings up uh
with makeup so is this strong evidence
of alleged abuse
well it's strong evidence in a sense
brian melanie iglesias was extremely
credible she met amber at the tribeca
film festival back in april 2015 and she
saw pictures of the quote unquote abuse
right before the james corden show in
december of 2016. and she was very
specific and she said she saw those in
person but the real issue here is
did she see what caused those injuries
and she testified that she did not every
single thing that she saw was just based
on what amber told her so that's not
absolutely evidence of the fact that
depth did that to her but she was very
credible that's a good question there
all right lisa
can you help me and probably most guys
like me who know very little to nothing
about makeup did any of this make sense
can you cover up these injuries with
makeup the way that she's describing
oh you sure can and she even said that
she did special effects what i found
interesting is she said she actually put
bruises on people she had that skill set
so not knowing whether or not
the presupposition is that she put
wounds on herself and that's what the
general public is saying so from her
being close up knowing what amber's face
looks like and knowing what to do to
cover cover wounds or injuries she would
be a pro at it especially working in the
special effects department so whether or
not what she said
she thought was authentic i think she
came across as very credible but like
terry said we don't know the source of
any of the injuries all right we'll see
what the jury decides when they get this
case eventually when we come back the
clock is ticking as we approach closing
arguments in the johnny depp amber heard
trial next we take a closer look at the
strict times line set up for each side
and explain how that could affect their
case
[Music]
welcome back as memorial day approaches
the clock is ticking for both sides and
the johnny depp v amber her defamation
trial but could a string of objections
from depp's team be a stalling tactic
law and crime network sierra gillespie
explains why we may have seen so many
objections
from the start of the trial judge penny
azkarati has issued a strict time limit
for each side
61 hours and 15 minutes some trial
watchers believe depp's team is trying
to run out the clock by issuing
countless objections
experts tell me though it's not depp's
team being tricky they're just doing
their job because i promised this jury
would be done by memorial day weekend
and we will be done by memorial day
weekend while issuing a time limit is
unusual law and crime legal analyst dina
dahl says it isn't unheard of it was
maybe for one because she knew it was
going to be televised and she was trying
to quite frankly control also the amount
of time for the fact that these you know
juries were already going to be sitting
for such a long time and while the clock
is ticking we've seen some pretty
memorable testimony
so it
made contact
and shattered i didn't know of the
bottle
that he had inside me was broken but
maybe the most memorable point of amber
heard's testimony is the number of
objections by depp's attorney camille
vasquez is that true objection your
honor leading her
foundation relating to your nose
objection leading consisting
foundation hearsay
what if anything that is not the cure
but dahl says it's not a calculated move
to use up time you know the amount of
objections we're seeing is actually
fairly typical in civil litigation i
mean it's a strategy for one thing
they're trying to throw quite frankly
the lawyer off of their train of thought
with the questioning of the witness and
also throw off the witness it makes it
also harder for the jury to kind of
follow the story and that famous
phrasing from herd's team what if
anything did you report to aaron
fellotti what if any production
did you make what
if anything
i'm trying i'm trying
that's just her attorneys doing their
job what they're trying to avoid is a
leading question we don't want the
lawyer to be testifying right we want
the witness to be testifying so there's
a rule that you can ask you know an
open-ended question and to get the
evidence that you want but the lawyer
can't kind of maybe remind the witness
of the testimony or try to kind of put
words in the mouth of the testimony and
so that's where that objection comes in
is are you leading the witness the
attorney is trying to get around that by
saying what if anything but then she
goes ahead and she leads the witness
with the rest of her question it's not
that the lawyers i think don't
understand the hearsay rule but they are
trying to get in this what they think
it's really good evidence
within one of the exceptions to the
hearsay rule and that's why the job of
basically the johnny depp's team is to
kind of hold them to
that general rule and say hey well you
know that exception doesn't apply while
the slew of objections and phrasing may
not be a tactic to stall the clock is
still ticking as we said from the very
beginning once time is up once your time
is up your time is up if it's in the
middle of a witness i'm going to stop
you
as of now closing arguments are expected
to be presented next friday on may 27th
reporting for long crime network i'm
sierra gillespie
thanks sierra just to give us an idea of
how much time is on the clock depth side
has 18 hours and 30 minutes
herd side has 8 hours and 14 minutes
lisa let's go to you first do you think
this was a wise move for the judge to
make this decision about timing and
where do you think we would be if she
didn't do it
well i have to tell you former military
i love time charts i love things to be
right on schedule and the fact that is
memorial day weekend and a week had
already been off i think it's good to
set set some type of parameter i think
it's only going to sharpen the pencils
for these lawyers and to make sure they
do what they need to do and it's concise
and there's not a lot of um extra hoopla
surrounding the case i like it
i agree now terry we heard the judge
saying if they're in the middle of a
witness it does that's it do you think
the judge is really going to hold their
feet to the fire that intensely
well she can try to hold their feet to
the fire listen i have tried dozens if
not hundreds of civil lawsuits and the
judge will try to hold your feet to the
fire they will try to set deadlines they
will try to limit how long you are up
there and the attorneys are going to try
to stick to those deadlines stick to
those limits but i've got to tell you
brian
if they go over i cannot see and i have
not heard of a judge cutting them off
and not giving them some sort of
extension and if that were to occur as
far as i'm concerned any of the parties
could either try to make a motion for a
mistrial which of course will not be
granted because it's the judge doing it
or they will appeal what is going on
they have every right to put on their
case they have every right to put in all
of the evidence unless there's some
reason that they are stalling and i
don't think that is occurring here so i
think she can try to set these limits
but at the end of the day the attorneys
will either abide by them or she'll give
them some sort of extension well let's
say herd side will run out of time first
we'll see how that plays out well thank
you both and thank you for joining us
here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you